Цей звук дедалі частіше тероризує столицю та інші міста України.
Наближається  "мопед". Так прозвали іранські дрони Shahed-136
за характерний гуркіт в повітрі. Наскільки вони небезпечні та як їм протидіяти?
Іран заперечує продаж своїх дронів Росії. Але за даними української розвідки,
Москва замовила у Тегерана приблизно 2400 безпілотників.
Дрони-камікадзе Shahed-136 маркують як "Герань-2".
Максимальна дальність польоту - до двох тисяч кілометрів, ефективна - до тисячі.
Крейсерська швидкість близько 180 кілометрів на годину.
Боєголовка містить до 40-50 кілограмів вибухівки.
Завдяки невеликому розміру
та низькій висоті польоту безпілотники складно виявити радарами систем протиповітряної обoрони.
Як правило, Росія зараз їх використовує над Дніпром.
Вони летять практично всі над річкою. По руслу річки.
Відповідно летить низько над річкою і це ще одна додаткова перешкода,
коли важко його (виявити). Коли летять ракети, все ж таки простіше.
У нас засоби виявлення є і поставлені в Україну додатково, тому ми це бачимо більше.
Іранські дрони доволі дешеві, зокрема через це їх і стала активно використовувати Росія,
адже ракет на складах дедалі менше, а на виробництво нових піде чимало часу.
До того ж багатьох компонентів бракує через західні санкції.
За оцінками експертів, один Shahed-136 коштує приблизно 20 000 євро,
тоді як ракета "Калібр" - шість мільйонів, а деякі види інших крилатих ракет - ще більше.
Очевидно, що у Росії закінчуються високоточні керовані боєприпаси.
У них, звісно, ще доволі багато інших ракет та артилерійських снарядів
- цієї старої зброї, але в них недостатня кількість високоточних ракет, керованих ракет.
Тому за рахунок дронів вони і хочуть досягти своїх цілей.
Розмір і низька висота польоту, що робить ці дрони важко помітними для ППО
- це одночасно і перевага, і недолік. Їх видно неозброєним оком,
добре чути через гучний звук і висоти польоту достатньо, щоб збивати стрілецькою зброєю.
На цьому відео Патрульної служби поліцейські у Києві збили один з дронів
зі звичайного автомата Калашникова.
За словами експертів, найефективніший спосіб знищення дронів-камікадзе
- загороджувальний вогонь, коли стріляють у фіксовану точку на шляху безпілотника
і він сам залітає у хмару куль.
При цьому МВС закликає власників зброї самостійно не намагатися збивати дрони,
особливо поміж багатоповерхівок, адже це може призвести до жертв серед цивільних.
Також можна застосовувати станції глушіння безпілотників, які допомагають
змінити точку призначення дрона та відвести його від житлових об'єктів.
Генсек НАТО Єнс Столтенберг запевнив, що Альянс надасть Києву
відповідні системи для боротьби з дронами.
Ці дрони, хоч і є дешевим замінником дорогих крилатих ракет,
все одно завдають великої шкоди, вбиваючи мирне населення
та руйнуючи критичну інфраструктуру.
Втім, на думку аналітиків та військових експертів,
іранські дрони не матимуть суттєвого впливу на хід війни.
Ця зброя - це зброя терору, це зброя залякування, яка покликана
посіяти паніку в першу чергу серед нас, українців. Не посіє. Так. Дуже боляче.
Так. Гинуть мирні мешканці. Так. Ворог лютує і казиться, але переламати
хід цієї війни ці дрони-камікадзе не зможуть.
Я впевнений у цьому на 100 відсотків.
Після атаки іранських дронів на Київ 17 жовтня під стінами посольства Ірану в Україні
активісти провели акцію протесту, звинувативши Іран у підтримці тероризму
та вбивстві українців. Протестувальники розкидали каміння з будинку,
в який влучив іранський безпілотник і вимагали припинити постачання Росії дронів-камікадзе.
Українське МЗС назвало Іран співучасником російської агресії,
воєнних злочинів та терактів Росії проти України.
А президент Зеленський закликав західних партнерів надати більше систем ППО.
Коли ми кажемо про потребу України в засобах протиповітряної
й протиракетної оборони, ми кажемо про реальні життя, які забирають терористи.
Нам вдається збивати частину ракет і дронів. Лише за 12 годин з 9-ї вечора неділі
вдалося знищити 37 іранських "Шахедів" і кілька крилатих ракет.
Але, щоб гарантовано захистити наше небо й звести до нуля можливості
російських терористів, потрібно значно більше сучасних систем ППО
і більше забезпечення ракетами для таких систем.
Україна також закликає накласти санкції на Іран за допомогу в агресії
Росії проти України. У США та ЄС вже обговорюють відповідні кроки.
За словами речниці Білого дому, є "всебічні докази" застосування Росією
іранської зброї проти цивільних цілей в Україні.